i am it's a show that's been furloughed
for 18 months which is a very odd
experience for a performer because i'll
be honest with you you get your mojo up
you know you get all going and excited
and you think this is what i want to
talk about it's really important and
then someone says yeah you have to leave
it now for 18 months and then do it
again it feels weird but i did do some
warm-ups the other day and the show
still seems to be working it's about
social media it's about the madness and
rage and craziness of social media and
that is at least i think still relevant
as it was 18 months ago possibly more
relevant
you do poke the beast on twitter don't
you
yeah i quite like doing that the thing
is that when it first started and you
know you've probably had experience a
bit as well of people being nasty to you
on social media and deciding that's what
the thing
that's the greatest thing about social
media the chance to upgrade people
you've never liked i didn't follow the
law which was don't feed the trolls and
the reason i didn't do that is that i've
had a long experience in comedy clubs of
people called hecklers and what they are
are people who shout abuse at you at the
dark
mainly for their own reasons because
they enjoy upsetting people and hurting
people and the way you deal with that is
try and make it funny you don't ignore
it and i do that on social media to the
best of my ability i don't ignore it i
screenshot the abuse and then i try and
say something funny about it and that
was the beginning of the show really is
to say let's see if instead of making
all this leaving all this hate to fester
or just getting really upset about it
let's see if we can make it funny and
the whole show is a cry for comedy it's
like saying is there a way in which
comedy which is very under scrutiny at
the moment and people get very angry
about everything a bit angry about jokes
and whatever let's just see if there's a
way of sort of being funny that won't
just upset people
yeah i mean i do get a lot of abuse on
twitter as well as you know because we
follow each other on twitter but you
know when people are particularly rude
to me saying how rubbish i am at my job
and how i should go away and die and
blah blah blah i usually put over the
top of that is that you son and that
tends to make people um you know go away
and leave me alone for a little while um
you talk about your dad on twitter quite
a lot don't you
yeah well yeah i do actually i mean
because part of what i try and do see
i'm a very um i'm an absurdly open
person i was thinking about the other
day as my wife who is an absurdly
private person also wonder how we ever
managed to get that together but i am i
just have to put everything about my
life uh out there i've always done that
i've always done that in comedy i did a
whole show about um before this show
about my mum my late mother's sex life
and my dad's dementia and what i noticed
was that if you
you know put that out in a certain way
then people really respond to it because
lots of people in the same situation as
me who've got a living reality of living
with dementia and i try and do it in a
way that feels again kind of it's the
same thing you know how can we take
something that's dark and difficult and
make it in a way joyful so i try and put
photos of my dad when he's smiling and
he's upbeat and you know and he's not
always like that but there are times
when he is and
it seems to really touch people and i'm
glad about that really and also i just
want my dad who is a really funny bloke
despite everything to sort of feel like
he's still in contact with the world
yeah you're writing a memoir aren't you
about your dad uh it's about my dad and
my mom it's basically based on that show
that i just i did that show before this
show which is about because she's called
trolls not the dolls like the show
called my family not the sitcom because
i've got this brand that means something
only to me which is called my show's not
the something and i did a show for two
years in the west end and all over the
world actually called my family not the
sitcom which was about my mum's sex life
my mom had a very long affair with a
golfing memorabilia salesman and went on
to become obsessed with golf and that
was part of the show and the other part
of the show was about my dad's dementia
and the way i deal with it and the way
i've managed to find comedy out of it uh
yeah i mean
it's just something that i like to do
i've always dealt with stuff dealt with
stuff in my life through comedy and as
you get older some of that stuff gets
more difficult and that doesn't stop me
dealing with it in the same way
how was how funny was it not winning the
euros
i was used to it
you know what i mean
that song that i believe you may know
and that people may have heard during
that tournament one thing it does do it
prepares you
for the disappointment because it's got
lines in it about all those oh so nears
and you know basically it's a song about
how we never win that's what that song
is about even though we sing it winning
the darwin winning it's a song really
about how we never win and so the good
thing about that is you know i've sort
of prepared for it
you know what
it was a great competitive gate
tournament
i was really pleased with the way the
team you know put themselves out there i
think we played incredibly well in the
recent games uh fantastically i thought
against hungary and so
onwards and upwards
what was it like when you were actually
at wembley for the final um because you
were there with mr skinner as well of
course i'm sure everybody wanted to have
pictures taken with you and shake your
hands and the like
yeah
well that's
a given i think when we go to football
and it's really really nice i'll be
honest with you actually i think the
biggest game for me and frank in that
tournament was not the final but it was
the germany game for our personal
reasons because in 1996 when that song
first came out uh frank i remember was
always banging on about how this is our
perfect summer uh and it's going to be
incredible england are going to win that
tournament and the song is going to be
sung everywhere
and it was sung everywhere but we didn't
win that tournament germany beat us in
the semi-final and there are shots you
can still find on youtube of me and
frank with ex-girlfriend standing in the
at wembley looking upset
and so the fact that we were there 25
years later to see england finally beat
germany and then the song was sung that
felt like a huge narrative redemptive
art for me and frank skinner